solve for C and graph the solution we
have negative 5c is less than or equal
to 15 so negative 5c is less than or
equal to 15 I just rewrote it a little
bit bigger so if you want to solve for C
we just want to isolate this C right
over here on maybe on the left hand side
we have its right now being multiplied
by negative 5 so the best way to just
have a C on the left hand side is we can
multiply both sides of this inequality
by the inverse of negative 5 or by
negative 1/5 and let me let me just so
we want to multiply negative 1/5 times
negative 5c and we also want to multiply
15 times negative 1/5 I'm just
multiplying both sides of the inequality
by the inverse of negative 5 because
when this will cancel out with the
negative 5 and leave me just with C now
I didn't draw the inequality here
because we have to remember if we
multiply or divide both sides of an
inequality by a negative number you have
to flip the inequality and we are doing
that we are multiplying both sides by
negative 1/5 which is the equivalent of
dividing both sides by negative 5 so we
need to turn this from a less than or
equal to a greater than or equal and now
we can proceed solving for C so negative
1/5 5th times negative 5 is 1 so the
left-hand side is just going to be C is
greater than or equal to 15 times
negative 1/5 that's the same thing as 15
divided by negative 5 and so that is
negative 3 so our solution is C is
greater than or equal to negative 3 and
let's graph it so that is my number line
let's say that is 0 negative 1 negative
2 negative 3 and then I could go above
1/2 and so C is greater than or equal to
negative 3 so it can be equal to
negative 3 so I'll fill that in right
over there let me do it in a different
color so I'll fill it in right over
there and then it's greater than as well
so it's all of these values I am I am
filling in in green and you can verify
that it works in the original inequality
pick something that should work well 0
should work 0
is one of the numbers that we've filled
in negative five times zero is zero
which is less than or equal to 15 it's
less than 15 now let's try a number
that's outside of it and I haven't drawn
it here I could continued with the
number line in this direction you would
have a negative 4 here negative 4 should
not be included and let's verify that
negative 4 doesn't work negative 4 times
negative 5 is positive 20 and positive
20 is not less than 15 so it's good that
we did not include negative 4 so this is
our solution this is it this is that
solution graphed now I wanted to do that
in that other green color here you go
that's what it looks like